et ça là-bas
c'est le groupe de Nandy du nom de la
magnifique matriarche que vous pouvez
voir au centre
oui elle est mal c'est Kuda et son jeune
frère K-way
par ici ah ouais vous êtes à l'abri ils
sont en train de terminer leur prise
d'hier soir tant mieux ouais c'est
complètement dingue
c'est comme ça que ça marche avec les
Lions les femelles partent chassées les
mâles protègent le groupe mais les
protège de quoi en général des autres
lions si à Lyon étranger à la famille
débarquait sur leur territoire
kodakaway j'ai très sur lui il est
tellement en pièce vous mourrez en
essayant la voix de la jungle
ça va
attends je vais aller voir dehors
[Musique]
vous avez rien vous avez rien
il va mourir si on fait rien